you
hi everyone it's Jerry i'ma and chest
coms tactics trainer and going to do
another group of three puzzles and
simply share my thoughts along the way
whoa this feels like a game that would
rival the immortal King Locke what is he
doing down here huh can be seven well
feels like there should be some mate we
are controlling a lot of squares around
the White King that White King is
currently stalemated other legal moves
on board he doesn't have any illegal
moves Queen is under fire
that's forcing rook b5 check forces King
h6 if the King goes to a8 rook to b8 is
mate it's 92 squares from the diagonal
square strong strong piece coordinated
with the rook the enemy king is close by
so rook the e5 King h6 it's another
forcing move coming up Rippey five king
h6 our rook is attacked we can make a
move with our Knight to b8 give check
and defend our rook that would then
force King a7 and then one
five king a6 would it really be night to
be eight feels like an awkward square
for our night only has a few options
from there at most that past rook b5
King a six night b8 King to a seven and
he has a couple squares hmm I don't feel
like that would be it
it's just really the first move rugby
five King a six
that doesn't feel right
so I'm check here
capture of our night won't work because
the king is ready to just run away on
these light squares
hmm do we have time for some quiet move
possibly hmm we may be able to do
something like King e7 and get one more
piece involved you know Brooke on b8
would be made hmm
like if King II 7 Queen takes rook we
take the Queen and then we're gonna get
this rook coming over here for a check
and then even Bishop to c8 next for
checkmate it feels a little too slow to
do this that's the start
hey it seems to work though at least in
the line with Queen takes rook white is
way underdeveloped hmm what more to
consider I mean I'm only looking at this
rook checking a slow move like king e7
as a starter hmm oh oh there's a quiet
move on move to still still connected
with this bishop c8 move instead of this
King e7 I was citing King e7 if I could
get the rook over here and when the king
is on this square Bishop to c8
well how about rook b8 check King a6 and
then one quiet move namely rook to b8
and we have exactly what I would want
would have wanted with this this King
rook the King rook on ba and then the
bishop here well rook b5 king a6 in one
column move rook to b8 and then you just
can't stop mate on the next move
gypsy ages came over night controls the
too dark we only need to control this
this square here where the White King is
and it cannot be prevented well that's
going to do it so I'm making three with
move to being a quiet move and that's oh
I'm mistaken it's not a main three man I
didn't see that there was this Queen
move that doesn't make me feel so good
hmm I mean I know how to still win but
yeah I mean we give a check Queen take
our queen blocks and then we could take
the rook and then return mm-hmm is that
going to be best one two and then three
I think that that should be fine okay
and the right idea but I should have at
least considered this Queen move okay
it's already saying it solved so they
would only have a queen block just
bringing up the analysis real quick rook
check rook here Queen there we give a
check the Queen could block
I don't believe taking with the Bishop
is correct because it allows the King to
now make use of b5 and then run away on
these light squares but just taking with
the rook it's not what's check but the
very next move is going to be a
discovered check mate okay right idea
but I should have at least considered
this Queen move I guess not too big of a
deal okay let's try another team white
again or not again we are black in that
last one
anyhow team white this time around
mmm-hmm okay we have Queen checks on H 5
and H 4 let's see how we do materialized
not too good
yeah we're down a boatload of material
here mm-hmm I see a way that we could
get the Queen my way of uh let's say a
check and then Knight f7 hitting the
Queen threatening Queen h8 mini but I'm
thinking we should shoot for something
strong or maybe maybe a mate on the H
file yeah
leaning towards this extra material that
black has is just way underdeveloped
Knight rook Bishop not contributing this
rook not doing so much the Queen and
Knight are the two black pieces that I'm
seeing have the possibility to defend
like some Queen sack of the night in
case he needs to be eliminated maybe the
night playing here and or to f6 and to
h6 stuff like that so these are the only
two defensive pieces I'm seeing on the
black end I'm thinking about Queen h5
and then Queen to f7 this is a really
dominant position for the Queen and it
set it controls these g3 squares
really well and may pave the way for a
rook up and over idea like rook f3 to h3
but I will have to factor in this Knight
f5 to h6 idea blocking some rook check
on the H file let's see
let's start with this let's consider
queen h5 King GA only move it really
does feel like it would be Queen f7
check next Oh guess what it is this idea
of rook up and over and it's not going
to matter if the night is on h6 because
we would actually capture it and the
Queen Knight tandem will be strong
enough to force mate with the Queen on
f7 possibilities for Queen g6 or maybe
even Knight to g6 depending on where the
King goes after we play Queen f7 so
Queen h5 King g8 Queen f7 suppose King
h8 on King AJ we play rook to f3 I
believe on whichever move we're going to
be playing rip to f3 next whichever
black King moved to h7 or h8 we play
rook to f3 looking for rook h3 game over
I don't see how you stop that in any
other way besides Knight f5 we still
come over to give check the knight must
block on h6
and we simply take the knight after pawn
takes rook we play Knight g6 and that's
me
the other variation is after queen h5
king g8 Queen f7 King h7 what are we
doing there
we're playing rock f3 Knight f5 I guess
he could has a couple of routes to h6 g8
our f5 but I'm thinking Knight f5 rook
h3 Knight blocks again with the King on
h7 we take the rook once more and this
pawn is pinned to the King King has to
take the rook and then we play queen g6
mate
have I covered everything I know I'm
really close with this line might there
be something I'm missing Queen h5 King
g8 Queen f7 King h7 rook f3 suppose
there isn't a knight move but instead a
king move to h6 and that could never
work they're just moving forward and
right into the right into whites teeth
rook h3 King g5 and rook h5 looks to do
it yeah that would be me alright I think
we have this one nailed give a check
recognise the strength of a queen
position on this f7 square and they're
going with King h8 and now we have the
one silent move that we can afford
rook h3 not f4 because this Knight move
would stop over up getting to the H file
not rook f3 to h3 however I take the
knight and then get mate these two
pieces super strong best combination of
pieces in the game Queen Knight tandem
alright let's try this last one whoa
there's a lot of stuff going on here
flying is black and we're in check Queen
is pinned
okay that's quite all right we need to
be accurate with a king move here if
it's not a king move Bishop here I don't
see that working so the trick here is to
find what is the key King move hmm how
we doing material wise black is up the
exchange
well our queen isn't a pin but also
their queen is unprotected and attacked
there's also possibilities for me
suppose King d6 if they're taking our
queen I believe that'll run into a
million two with rook takes rook King f2
when we promote get a queen and give me
we have f3 covered by our Bishop I'm
leaning towards King d6
but I'm a little concerned about a
knight move to f5 with Chuck
which makes me immediately reconsider
King d6 and maybe I should be looking
more into King d7 this too would allow a
check with the bishop on f5 but after
the bishop plays to f5 then we could
scoot our king up 1 square to d6 oh but
then that allows a bishop check and our
King is still running for his life huh
let's hang on for a moment if King d6
Knight check and we just not
can't we just take the night what's
wrong with that I think we could gain d6
I hope Bishop takes Queen covered
there's a night check and also rook
takes rook no scratch rook takes rook
that's not working
King d6 rook takes rook game over with
Queen f1 okay so King d6 I have no fear
of Bishop takes Queen I have no fear of
rook takes rook no fear of Queen takes
rook either because we just recapture
and it's still the same story in that
case with Bishop takes Queen we would
take the rook and then promote so king
d6 I'm not fearful of Bishop takes Queen
because it rook takes rook and then
promoting King d6 not afraid of Queen
takes rook on EA tor rook takes e8
so the only other move to consider after
king d6 is this Knight check and I
believe we could just take them our
other pretty serious threat to of them
actually is to take the knight with
Chuck and to simply grab the rook or
grab the Queen on h8 King d6 Knight f5 I
think is the only thing to consider now
and I'm pretty sure we could just scoop
that Knight up yeah
we're just going to
the night if he goes here I don't think
any other night move it's so good oh
hang on for a moment here huh hmm King
d6 night check Queen takes Knight I
wonder if there's some in-between move
like rook here maybe but it really began
that complicated King d6 Knight f5 Queen
takes Knight rook check first and then
position though hmm there might be a
clever move in d6 Knight f5 would we
really just make a King move yeah I
still think we could take the knight
King design to five we take the knight
let's say rook d1 check King here to c7
yeah that should work because
why exactly hmm it's still a bit tricky
having trouble working out what to do
after King to rook to d1 there when is
nf5 King his on d6 he's in check
no white knight on the board what would
we do here that I mean there's a queen
block but they could take our queen
let's check we would
sure we're on the Queen and threatening
this although there is Queen h4 hmm I
mean another ideas after King g6 9 to 5
we take the knight rook check if we
block with the Queen to get out of the
line of fire by the bishop
and white doesn't necessarily have to
take our pinned piece right away they
could rescue their queen should I be can
in king d7
maybe yeah maybe I should
King d7 Bishop f5 check I stopped my
calculations earlier with this line
after I saw there was Bishop f4 check
but if Bishop f4 check we don't have any
more worried of our queen but they might
be able to just grab our rook on e85 on
out 5 these earlier mentioned ideas with
mating enough 1 we don't have them
anymore if there's the bishop on f5 and
then this is tricky I'm not sure what
the differences are between these two I
mean clearly King d6 King d7 tough for
me to work these two out let me stick
with it for just a little bit more
wouldn't be the first time I've spent a
lot of time on one puzzle let's see
there's some key idea I'm missing here
must be can t69 f5 do we really even
have to take the knight
just my concern
is that where King is going to get
checked like crazy king daeso King d7
Bishop f5 King c7 suppose then rook
takes rook well that might be it
actually walk our King over to c7 if
rook takes rook we can first take this
night with check if the bishop blocks we
take the bishop and after the rook
recaptures we get this the Queen in the
corner and after the smoke clears we are
up a minor piece hmm King d7 Bishop f5
King c7 mana there's also a rook on c1
check Bishop f4 check with our King on
c7 is really not an issue because of
King to b6 and there isn't a good
follow-up check King d7 Bishop f5 King
c7 rook c1 check concerns me
I'm right about ready to give up um if I
haven't gotten it I don't know I don't
know I'm at that moment I'm really close
to throwing in the towel here 11 minutes
in to this puzzle
yikes ah once again ready to revisit d6
96 95 take the knight my only concern
with that variation was this rook check
do I have something better
oh maybe I do
King d69 f5 Queen takes Knight rook
check just lock with the bishop maybe I
don't know yeah this is this is tough I
don't like to do this but I'm going to
kind of gamble here and maybe see if I
could get it as I just removed the
pieces some not really the way to solve
it but yeah I'm just not seeing this one
I'm gonna try for and try for King to d6
oh my goodness and that's the variation
cause what I know what I'm doing in this
one solved
see how easy you see how easy it is yes
I'm very satisfied with that one
can you tell mmm King d6 what am i doing
in there
yeah really what am i doing on that move
can I work it out by moving the pieces
around night Chuck captures here my
concern was rook check now what yeah
really what are we doing here and they
check something else I don't know this
one is still confusing to me it's at
least for me this wasn't the most
testing line in the capture of the Queen
after King d6 just walking right into a
mate here yeah I mean nine to five if
they're taking like this we have mate
they'd have five what are we really
doing are we moving our king or taking
the night I guess we could just move the
King back here I didn't mention this and
that's that
it's out of the way of these rook moves
with check to our King I think it would
be king to c7 and then if there's an
ensuing check with the bishop what are
we doing here I guess we could play our
King here and we even have some ideas if
this rook leaves we have ideas and I
didn't even consider this I was a long
way off from considering this but we
have Queen a1 ideas and then promoting
if the rook leaves capturing here we
have this check and then we're getting a
new clean with me mm-hmm
I guess that this is what it would be
maybe I'll throw that to you viewer if
you're still here is would this be the
best reply if Knight to f5 is played
King to c7 I'll throw that one at you I
think it's a bad idea to not have a
complete closure to this one I'll throw
it at you uuhh chess fanatics computer
whiz is out there don't consult with the
computer see if you can figure it out on
your own is king c7 the best reply on
Knight to f5 tell me what you think in
the comment section below and yeah
discuss it in the comments section flow
okay well not the greatest end to this
group of three I think my favorite was
that second one feel free to share as
usual how you did with these three in
the comment section below and I'll catch
you in the next video I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you